you've got a great film here great cast
among young the truth about fishes it's
a strong film for female characters
isn't it so how did it feel playing
cards boyfriend amiss I know there's a
lot of female kind of vibe spoon honest
especially like Francesca directed being
female produces and you know a lot of
people behind the screen you know the
dop was female so the men were kind of
pushed to the side and this one it's
really nice actually to get in there be
involved with such a wonderful bunch of
wonderful women really and to be
involved in a complex story you know
which is revolving around you know a
female kind of audience and plot line so
then to be one of the only men in its is
quite a nice privilege yeah so I'll take
that one yeah what was it like working
with kaya and also this alfred molina
you got Jessica Biel in there as well a
car yeah it was a ice truck quite lucky
you know and you strike gold I suppose
and there you know caius boyfriend as
you know on screens good fun and you
know we enjoyed that and the
relationship is kind of on and off you
know within the film which is quite fun
to play with when you're acting and
working that through and of course
having a familiar play in the father of
my girlfriend you know what Alfred in
real life is works so lovely and
wonderful and charming and kind and soft
and then playing the daunting father you
know it's quite it's quite nice dynamic
to kind of play on screen so a lot of
enjoyment through that you know and then
of course you know Jessica's extra stuff
you know and Korea's just blooming and
blooming you know and I kind of mat met
here in the middle of their Korean Chi
has now become a new kind of big massive
lovely leading actress and it's nice to
kind of cusp that with both kind of
and people in different places in their
lives new but very busy young man you
had a lot of films out of the last
couple years and you got a lot of films
it you involved in at the moment haven't
you let's talk a little bit about ones
to come you've got Brian Mundy and the
Midas box what are you looking forward
to you about that I showed Mariah Mundi
last week the first time so it was a big
kind of God but you know aveer because
you know when you're leading like an
action like a family kind of action
movie it's it's a big weight on your
shoulders especially when it's based on
a series of novels and I had a lot of
fun doing that and we went back to kind
of old school kind of filmmaking you
know and I do in my own stunts and all
that stuff so it's a lot of fun and
hopefully that kind of transcends on the
screen and you know they know like it's
not an Indiana Jones movie it says your
own story but you know when I was
growing up and I used to watch that I
just used to imagine doing that one day
and this is the closest I got to doing
that thus far so hopefully it's exciting
it's thrilling and stories come complex
and people can really kind of just throw
themselves within it did you say it's
going to be a series of books isn't it
so this could be the massive franchise
that catapults you in the front of
everybody how do you go without to think
how would it change your life
and not much really it's more kind of
you know there's a lot more to deal with
than that and but I've got two wonderful
parents who keep my feet firmly on the
ground a wonderful girlfriend and great
friends so therefore I won't change much
but maybe my career will change quite a
lot on that exciting now it's been
lovely to speak to you and lots of luck
with all the films and futures very
challenging
you